[Música]
me dijeron piensa en una idea que hable
sobrepasar sus límites pasar las
barreras de la vida y además impactar
positivamente en el mundo y yo dije ok
ok ok lo voy a pensar pero
lamentablemente no es tan fácil como
subir y darles un tip sencillo no hay
hagan esto punto ahí está no creo que
nada de nuestro exterior nos puede
funcionar para realmente sobrepasar
nuestros límites creo que todo viene
desde el interior y obviamente todos
tienen que hablar desde su experiencia
desde sus vivencias y por eso es que hoy
voy a hablarles un poquito de mí
ok yo creo que todos tenemos bayas que
pasar a diferentes niveles en diferentes
alturas y diferentes dificultades pero
para mí ninguna es imposible de saltar
hoy miro hacia atrás y no me creo lo que
he logrado pero luego recuerdo que fui
yo quien lo hice y lo creo
me choca esta pregunta cómo te ves en 5
o 10 años
si le preguntaras al adiós de hace cinco
años como se veía no tenía ni idea que
iba a contestar a la de hace 10 - apenas
empezaba a existir youtube o sea esta
pregunta es imposible contestar nadie es
adivino del futuro además yo creo que
proyectar tus metas a tan largo plazo es
contraproducente porque porque tienes
que enfocar las en el hoy en el ahorita
en tu presente o en tu futuro inmediato
cuando tenemos 18 años la sociedad nos
obliga por no decir que nos invita a
estudiar una carrera y es algo horrible
porque a los 18 años si eres inmaduro no
sabes qué quieres de la vida te gustan 2
o 3 personas al mismo tiempo
no tienes ni idea y entonces ahí estás
tú aventando te por el tobogán de la
vida cruzando los dedos rezando
esperando que hayas tomado la mejor
decisión de escoger la carrera que más
te late los que no sabemos qué estudiar
generalmente estudiamos comunicación
porque en comunicación ves todo y ves
nada
es chistoso porque todos los que estaban
en mi generación pues se dedican a cosas
diferentes hoy en día yo soy creadora de
contenido uno de mis mejores amigos es
chef otra amiga trabaja en pemex
pues así cada quien es diferente la
mayoría acaban en agencias de publicidad
entonces yo me pregunto por qué demonios
no estudiaron publicidad pero bueno eso
ya es otra historia
la verdad es que yo quería estudiar si
me no pude hacerlo porque mis papás no
tenían el dinero para pagarme esa
carrera
entonces a diferencia de todos mis demás
compañeros de la carrera es que yo sí
sabía que quería la mayoría no tenía ni
idea era así como después estudié
comunicación porque no sé este me gusta
comunicar ahora le no pues chido
yo sabía que me gustaban los medios
desde muy chiquita empecé a hacer
televisión y soñaba con ser locutora de
radio me encantaban las películas
yo siempre tuve muy claro que era lo que
quería mi sueño era hacerlo contra el
radio y estar en los medios eso era lo
que diferenciaba a mis compañeros
conmigo el problema es que la carrera de
comunicación la radio te la dan hasta
los últimos semestres entonces pues no
me iba a quedar con los brazos cruzados
esperando pues saber en qué momento me
iban a enseñar lo que yo realmente
quería saber que hice
cruce del límite me puse las pilas
empecé a buscar chambitas y así es como
llegué a conseguir mi primer trabajo a
los 19 años
un programa de televisión más bien que
fue un programa de televisión que se
llamaba pulpo ese a dsb en este trabajo
me ofrecieron 15 mil pesos mensuales
era full time entonces tenía que
renunciar a mi carrera lo hice por
supuesto 15 mil pesos para mí en ese
entonces era guau nunca he ganado eso y
me pagaban por ser conductora claro no
nada más fui conductora era la
productora era la que eché cada edición
la que conseguía la ocasión es la que
conseguía entrevistas es más tenía que
editar los guiones porque el guionista
era tan descarado y tan malo que copiaba
las cosas de wikipedia copy-paste y les
dejaba el editar entre paréntesis
entonces pues al final era mi imagen y
yo tenía que pues estar modificando
todos los guiones ahora que si me
preguntas si valen 15 mil pesos lo todo
lo que yo hacía la verdad es que no no
lo haría pero lo valió porque
aprendí mucho por eso dicen que la
práctica hace al maestro y no la escuela
ojo no estoy diciendo que no estudian la
carrera bla bla estoy hablando desde mi
experiencia para mí como fue hace dos
años y medio de carrera y mi carrera
siguió pero en el trabajo
como todo principio tiene su fin se
acabó mi programa y estuvo muy triste me
deprimí muchísimo llore para mí se había
acabado el mundo me despidieron me
despidieron no porque yo haya hecho algo
malo sino porque cambiaron la
programación
pues me dijeron adiós entonces pues yo
era muy chavita y pensaba que se estaba
acabando el mundo pero todavía no
aprendí a que la vida es cambiante y ahí
me tienes a mí deprimida sin trabajo sin
carrera y con un perrito bebé nuevo que
mantener porque se me hizo fácil
que hice me puse las pilas me puse a
buscar cosas empecé a hacer miles de
castings de los cuales de miles también
me rechazaron me metí a cursos de cosas
que a mí me gustaban cursos de locución
cursos de doblaje y cursos de actuación
y finalmente vi esta oportunidad de
empezar a hacer vídeos en una plataforma
y dije ok wow esto es algo que ya he
hecho anteriormente como en la
televisión pero esto va a ser 100% mi
responsabilidad nadie me va a decir está
bien está mal tienes que decir esto o
lete este guión de wikipedia no esto va
a ser mi onda y para mí era un gran reto
para mi creatividad para mi persona para
todo y dije ahora le lo voy a empezar a
hacer la realidad es que yo tenía en
mente que si yo hacía algo bien ahí pues
me van a jalar de la tele me van a jalar
de la radio me va de más hablar de otros
lados y si tenía razón me empezaron a
jalar de diferentes televisoras empecé a
hacer unitarios que son como la rosa de
guadalupe estas cosas nunca estuve la
rosa tranquilos
ya sé que oso pero en ese momento
aprendí mucho era algo muy cool y llegó
el trabajo de mis sueños
así es llegué a ser locutora de radio
quería sacar provecho a esta voz sexy y
ronca que tengo y fue mi primer trabajo
godín como tal el primer trabajo en una
empresa donde pues es como old school
donde todo es muy limitado donde tienes
que hacer horas nalgas y no horas de
calidad y empecé a tener muchos choques
mentales empecé a sufrir por primera vez
ataques de ansiedad y yo decía guau
o sea mi mundo colapsó como es posible
tener trabajo de mi sueño siempre soñé
ser locutora trabajaba en la tele me
invitaban a conducir los juegos
olímpicos' el superbowl tenía
protagónicos en unitarios hacia todo lo
que yo quería y era infeliz tenía
ataques de ansiedad y me di cuenta ahí
que no siempre lo que sueñas es lo que
verdad quieres
y eso es algo muy difícil de aceptar
porque te imaginaste toda tu vida en tal
cosa y de repente llega si dices pues no
qué pasó ahí
que me limito me limito como nunca me
había limitado ese trabajo era una
empresa que no me dejaba crecer me
acuerdo perfecto cuando renuncie di las
gracias y le dije perdón pero aquí no me
dejan crecer me están limitando y
entonces me salí renuncie y empecé a
enfocarme en lo que en verdad tenía que
enfocarme en cosas que tenían
importancia empecé a ser libre
encontré libertad libertad de
creatividad libertad de tiempo libertad
de hacer lo que yo quisiera y esa
libertad me dio evolución esa libertad
hizo que yo avanzara que todo fluyera
empecé enfocarme en mis vídeos en mis
cosas a la gente le empezó a gustar
fluyo y así fui creciendo paulatinamente
todo fue avanzando todo muy bonito
obviamente enfocándome en mis
habilidades porque acuérdense de que el
que mucho abarca poco aprieta como la
carrera de comunicación
hay gente que de repente dice no quiero
hacer esto esto y esto y estoy estoy
esto sí pero espérate hay que enfocarse
un poquito
no hay mejor manera que auto observarse
pero objetivamente no porque uno se
puede echar muchas flores pero hay que
ser objetivo de repente hay que salirnos
un poco de este cuerpo y vernos y decir
ok para que soy buena que se me da en mi
caso pues yo vi que era muy buena
desenvolviendo me no me daba pena la
cámara era muy movida se me daba la onda
de producir o sea empecé a ver mis
habilidades y sobre eso me fue enfocando
y las fui desarrollando porque a veces
hay gente que no sé se le metió a la
idea una cabeza y conozco a muchos que
dicen quiero ser actor quiero ser actriz
pero nadie les dijo que mal son actuando
lo hacen muy mal y aún peor que nadie
les dice aún peor no se dan cuenta ellos
solos ellos solos no pueden auto
observarse y decir ok no se me da no
tengo ese talento entonces si es muy
importante encontrar tus habilidades
encontrar tus talentos y sobre eso
enfocarte no querer acaparar todo y no
querer ser una persona impedida de no es
que yo dije que quería ser
y entonces voy a ser actor sí pero en
realidad traes el talento y no importa
qué talento tengas puede que tanto es
muy bonito pues que actúes padrísimo
pero también si no lo pones en práctica
no te sirve pónganse a prueba esto es lo
que yo les vengo a decir el día de hoy
pónganse a prueba lo que ustedes tienen
en mente y lo que sueñan ok ahí está
háganlo inténtenlo yo quería ser
locutora lo intenté lo busque lo logré
lo soñé y lo logré después me di cuenta
que no era lo que yo quería que no era
realmente lo que a mí me funcionaba pero
lo hice
así que trabajando en el presente en el
hoy dando lo mejor de ti día a día
haciendo las cosas de la manera más
inteligente posible para saber si dónde
está sembrando frutos dios dónde está
sembrando semillas realmente está dando
frutos y también siendo lo
suficientemente inteligente para saber
si eso te está limitando y saber lo
soltar y seguir por el camino donde
fluye y dónde vas evolucionando es como
solito va fluyendo tu vida va
evolucionando y ya no te tienes que
preocupar por el futuro ya no importa
cómo te ves en 5 o en 10 años porque
realmente lo que importa es hoy
que ya pasaste más allá de tus límites o
de los que creías que eran tus límites
así que recuerda si haces bien las cosas
hoy lo que venga mañana será mejor
gracias
[Aplausos]